what would have been the comic of Hana
Island from what's going on now what
would she say well I run the Hana and
center I found the Honduran center one
of the one of the pitfalls of being in
this position is people ask you what
would Hana aren't say I I hazard to
speak for her so what I try and do is
speak for myself but informed by her
thinking and hope that that's good
enough I'm not gonna channel Hana I run
from the grave um
harren loved it when unexpected things
happened in politics she that she thinks
and thought that spontaneity newness she
used the word mentality which is often
misused and abused in her work by others
but it means both worthiness and she
thought that what made human beings
different from other animals is that not
that we were rational but that we could
start things new that we were free and
it's that amazing freedom which she says
that in even the darkest times gives us
hope that something good can emerge
something new and so she always was
attracted to moments in history moments
in politics when a new thing broke out
so the Hungarian Revolution was very
meaningful and attractive to her the
protest movements in the 60s were very
meaningful and a tronic
tractors are both in the United States
and also in Europe the civil rights
movement was something she was very
engaged in um inevitably she found
things to worry about and not like about
a lot of these movements they they often
had negative outcomes or negative
attributes or characteristics that she
found troublesome but she
we found the new exciting and to the
extent were in a moment around the world
in Europe and and elsewhere but also the
United States where there's a a real
sense around the world that liberal
representative democracy is failing and
is illegitimate and that this way of
governing ourselves that has really been
the great success story of the last 250
years is is ceasing to to hold its old
people and convince people that it works
um there's no doubt that we're in a
moment when lots of new ideas are going
to emerge and she would like that I
think she would be skeptical of many of
the ideas that have emerged so on the
right I think she'd be excited by a lot
of what the tea party represents um she
was a one of the most important aspects
of her work was her real fear and belief
that centralization the centralization
of power into one institution or to a
powerful center with the greatest threat
to freedom and I think she would see the
Tea Party in its fear of and opposition
to centralization and bureaucratization
and federal power she would see a lot to
like in the Tea Party but in its in a
sort of low class racism and
anti-immigrant stances she would be very
fearful of it I think I'm the same on
the on the Left with Occupy Wall Street
or with Bernie Sanders campaign there's
a lot she would like about it she loves
it when young people had fun in politics
and by the way both on the left on the
right the Tea Party with their uniforms
and their hats but also the Occupy Wall
Street with it sort of really just being
together and having fun talking about
politics I think she would
I'm sure she would have found very
welcome but the sort of single-minded
focus on inequality and money both of
which are important and are without a
doubt problems in our society on the
idea that we're going to solve those
problems through a kind of socialism or
democratic socialism she would I think
largely have found again problematic she
thought socialism were ideas that had
been tried and failed throughout the
world generally led to tyranny and
totalitarianism she thought that it was
fairly obvious at this day and age that
as bad as capitalism was because it
expropriated people by the rich
socialism was just as bad and I was
expropriated people by the government
and I think she would be very worried
that the the sort of simple-minded
return to in her mind discredit that
ideas on the left was was not leading
toward something new it was actually
leading to something stale and old